[Music]
guys with ti9 right around the corner
let me go ahead and state the obvious
the International is the singular event
around which all of dota 2 revolves it's
a shot at millions of dollars and glory
for the winning team but when you're out
there on the grandest stage of them all
and everybody's watching it takes much
more than just a good play to make
history it takes something legendary
[Applause]
[Music]
so from Aegis snatches to wombo combo 2
epic turnarounds here are the top 10
most legendary plays from the
international kicking off our list is a
play that's as famous as it is
controversial that's right we're talking
about na vi's infamous fountain hook
strategy from the International 2013
going up against tongfu in the upper
bracket semi-finals Navi found
themselves on the brink of defeat in a
deciding game three this is really
troublesome for Navi the game was on the
edge and we could lose it like any
moment I was sure about that with their
backs against the wall Dendi and puppey
realized there was only one way one
strategy that would help them mount a
comeback
after successfully hooking tongfu into
the fountain multiple times
na'vi were able to snatch victory from
the jaws of defeat and advance to the
winner's fine when they were I saw enemy
around I'll ask Papa to community pin me
and I will try cooking there we go the
hook
coming in at number nine is Moo she's
iconic death profit escape against G at
ti4
geniuses vs. tu d cane game one after
counter pushing the mid lane and forcing
Evil Geniuses back to defend Russia
retreated to what he thought would be
safety in the top lane but nothing could
be further from the truth
as three members of PG were hiding under
the guise of moonlight shadow hunting
for the Malaysian mid later they've just
Solingen us completely with this rule so
this is not a good spot to be in right
now
they get a committee Robert he's running
himself away
[Music]
negative energy
[Applause]
[Music]
coming in at number eight is this
awe-inspiring Rubik play against cloud
nine from TI fives lower bracket
courtesy of FY first lines here jump in
not only does FY set up the first kill
and fought a shadow feed but he also
stole supernova and nightmare further
baiting cloud9 and earning vici gaming
an extra three kills killed a lamb is
reaches stunt him up a little bit slow
down the daggers there as well don't
tell they actually managed to get a
really good set my jumping
it's gonna go down he slipped itself
four steps away trying to get some
distant death really but will not be
able to get away
[Applause]
did that he steal the sleep he somehow
gets the egg completely turns the fight
around vici gaming with the wife of the
century taking the number seven spot on
our list is evil Joyce's legendary six
million dollar echo slam in the grand
finals of the International 2015 versus
evil geniuses on the brink of defeat see
Dec made a risky decision to try to take
Roshan after picking off sumail storm
spirit but evil geniuses had other plans
and contested c-tec
with an earth-shattering wombo combo
that was heard around the world
[Applause]
not only did this play when eg the
tournament it also made millionaires of
n A's first ages winning team
coming in at number six is mu she's
classic shadowfiend requiem kill on
burnings Weaver
at the International 2013 down one game
and on the brink of elimination time was
running out for Team Orange to mount a
comeback against the seemingly
unstoppable team DK big open three to
catch out in a shocker
so this ripping clerk my ex-wife but
being down three teammates didn't stop
Russia and Ohio from standing their
ground and landing this perfectly time
vacuum into Requiem of souls combo
burning trying to catch up to him in
time he's gonna wait for this surge it's
level two
[Music]
that burning it's a trap
this is why he's of
selfie button making its way in if the
halfway point is Sam's legendary ax call
from Game four of the International 2018
grand finals
yes [ __ ] yes now picture this you're
down to 1 against PSG LGD and Ti AIDS
Grand Finals and competing for the
largest prize pool in eSports history
and then when everything looks to be
going against you this happens
[Music]
that gets up to talk to Deputy Minister
Liana Anna can you do it here he's in
our mouth
the pressure was all unset to save honor
and keep oh geez dreams of pushing the
series to a game five decider match
alive and once he did oh gee managed to
pull off one of the greatest underdog
stories in the history of eSports
[Applause]
coming in at number four is s fours
million dollar dream coil in Game five
of the International 2013 grand finals
national number three both teams trying
to go home with 1.4 million dollars and
of course the lovely aegis and that that
one mattered suffering from a poor
laning phase Alliance were playing from
behind for the majority of the game and
realized the only way that could
possibly win was to employ one of their
signature strategies rat dota but no
boots of travel they go for the throat
it could be game buttocks down Julius
but on Stefan
that Japanese
it's good be the right standard
then these back he's gonna try to focus
everybody but there's so much stuff
there's no more clips available that of
a half-inch P a coronary Alliance
surrounding from informes de me
they're gonna do it
just smaller
your international stream
[Music]
taking the third spot on our list is off
ooh and his legendary steep in the night
ages steel against virtus pro in the
upper bracket of the International 2017
unable to contest VP's Roshan attempt
LGD foreveryoung sent off who's Earth
Spirit on an impossible mission to steal
the ages
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this goosebump inducing play shows off
off those nerves of steel as he rolls
blindly into the Rosh pit steals the
ages and rolls on out afterwards
[Applause]
coming in at the runner-up spot is Kaka
and his unreal earth spirit safe against
evil geniuses in the quarterfinals of
the International 2017 now look you
might not think this is deserving of the
number-2 spot but hear us out on this
one because this was a truly next-level
play things were looking grim for Evil
Geniuses as they made a desperate
last-ditch effort at taking out kpi's
bristle back and they threw everything
they had at him seriously black hole
into epicenter interpreters sight a
deadly combo that should have resulted
into certain death if it weren't for
Kaka's incredible save
[Music]
with a negative scepter and hand cock-up
LinkedIn and turned kpi to stone dodging
the male's ultimate in the process he
then kicked the bristle back to safety
before sacrificing his own life
[Applause]
the agony is a sprout believe me only
just mix it up Oh weeping cave me alive
my god that was absolutely beautiful
coming in at number one is a legendary
moment that went down in history simply
known as the play in Game two of T ITU's
upper bracket semi-finals Invictus
gaming thought they had the upper hand
as they caught all of Navi with Nagas
song of the siren but little did they
know things were about to get real bad
real fast
the shorter pad they swarm up the river
patients from so waiting the wig
Bobbi's about to be caught oh there's
been sleep but sir he catches everyone
I mean that - I'm trying to survive
which one's gonna come down
we talked about the nagas counter that's
why the Bevin
we can be dick turning around standing
ovation from the crowd with light of
heavens black king bar allowing him to
cast black hole and dendi stealing tide
hunters ravage na'vi were able to turn
around the gank and wipe Invictus gaming
in the process
while it may not be as impressive by
today's standards it was truly
innovative at the time and proved to be
one of the most iconic turnarounds in
dota2 history
[Applause]
well guys that's our list will any
moments from ti9 make a future top 10
video only time will tell but until then
it's up to the channel like the video
and let us know in the comments below
what we should do next from the world of
dota 2 thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else it up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages